unbelievable Jeff I bring them Stanley -
just a failed 100 City 5 tell them down
hill hi come on and I'm here to read you
a bedtime story that's being written for
me by someone on the internet about my
favorite person me may be wondering why
I'm whispering it's because the
producers told me and that's the way I'm
gonna do it
close your eyes take a deep breath
[Music]
[Music]
it was won by D'Amico Sunday afternoon
and of course he's [ __ ] his hat but
luckily dressed Kamara's thick glossy
impossibly curly locks were keeping him
toasty he wanted to darbian fall from
his position perched at the top of the
stands like a great football commentator
Tamarra found himself glancing down at
his bone his eyes flicker intently in
Baku with spring breeze he opened in the
sacrum and went straight to his own
profile page he sprawled idlies through
his old photos until he stopped on a
pitcher of his young yourself a
throwback to his playing days
his attention was magnificently drawn to
those ringlets which longer in those
days cascaded down he's nicked my hairy
waterfall he placed his star more than
four finger on the screen and slowly
bonded them Suman in the capture is
glorious detail for Chris it was perfect
it was smooth compact and overflowing
with energy like a crisp surely god of
an admiration to this place one hand on
his head and began to run it through his
girls let endless silky strands of his
sneakers
as he continued to run his hands through
his hair he lowered his eyes and let
himself be overtaken by the heavenly
failure of the hair on skin Smaug adhere
as smooth voice in his head between
those four special words what's the
latest cami press bet the words was over
him like a warm tired as he felt himself
becoming weightless floating slowly up
into the sky
[Music]
tell me are you okay something wrong
with your head it's not been a problem
of his temporary trance
Chris hurriedly removed his arm from his
hair and open his eyes to see the red
light glowing on the top of the camera
in front of him
he was on air The Voice coming across
his air base was Jeff he's go presenter
back in the studio
Chris's mouth dried like a dehydrated
raise it if he was honest yeah
no idea what was going on but he was a
professional and he knew this show was
gone took another deep breath this fall
full of just lips together releasing
their movement I'm stuck in his brain
for something anything to say their mind
is embarrassing predicament
I was just thinking about beavers how
the opposition of fire alight beavers be
fattening for their lives
hi beaver say those ferocious little
devils
Jeff's naked bank sarcastically steps
poised faded it easier a huge surgery
believe cost every crevice of Chris's
manly sculpted body by so incredible
stroke of law he thought the way with it
again one close goal was quiet enough
for Gary and he resolved to pay close
attention to the rest of the game at
that very moment as the away teams snow
strike there was steadied himself to
shoot a defender shoved him sending him
tumbling to the floor
players running from all angles that
argue with the referee and a wall of
deafening cheers could be heard from
around the stadium he tapped his mic
I'm waited for the studio to go back to
him
this is absolute all dryer football
it's all blend down here Jeff he shouted
through his mind never mind us I want to
talk to you about something that's been
sent in by on Twitter came Jeff's reply
confused but his beard at the tiny
citizens monitor in front of him he
could see a photo presumably taken by a
nearby phone in which brace could barely
be seen looking at his phone on the
phone screen filling it like a glowing
beacon a vampire sermon was the photo of
the princely young Chris Kamara then
it's so dingy less than an hour ago
the caption above
read find someone who looks at you the
same way as Kumar alongside press come
over had already been retweeted a
thousand times sign this realize what
happen she wanted more than anything to
unravel his beloved girls locks and pull
em over his glistening eyes to hide his
shame
instead even the only words he could
think of to describe how he felt at that
moment in time o believable Jeff
good night everybody
[Music]